.
Es ist, als wäre in mir
drin ein schwarzes Loch.
Und alles, was je zu mir gehört hat,
wird einfach dort reingezogen
und verschwindet in der Dunkelheit.
Das, was ich jetzt erlebe,
ist jenseits von allem,
was ich je erlebt habe.
Ein gravierender Punkt war,
dass ich fast eineinhalb Monate
gearbeitet habe
und nicht mehr schlafen konnte.
Ich habe noch so zwischen
1 und 2 Std. geschlafen.
Burnout ist allgegenwärtig.
Die gängige Deutung:
Es geht um eine Überlastung im Beruf,
die zum Zusammenbruch führt.
Aber so einfach ist es nicht.
Wenn ich wünschen könnte,
wäre ich froh,
man hätte den Begriff Burnout
nie so eingeführt.
Weil irgendwo ist er eine Bagatel-
lisierung von psychischen Problemen.
Burnout
ist viel mehr als Stress allein.
Das Leiden der Betroffenen ist gross.
Schlussendlich
waren es Existenzängste.
Es war Angst vor einem Absturz,
einem völligen Absturz
in meinem Leben.
Ich hatte vor allem Angst.
Drei Menschen mit Burnout, drei
völlig unterschiedliche Geschichten.
Eine Langzeitbeobachtung,
die vor Corona den Anfang nahm.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Düstere Klänge *
Es ist total verrückt.
Ich sagte immer, Kerzenziehen
ist meine Burnout-Prävention.
Das ist etwas Meditatives, Schönes.
Schlussendlich
habe ich mit dem Kerzenziehen
eine schöne Feuersbrunst
veranstaltet.
Ich wollte
die letzten Kerzen fertigmachen.
Ich war aber
voll im Abschlussstress,
im Geschäftsabschlussstress.
Ich wollte das über den Mittag
fertigmachen - flink flink.
Plötzlich fing alles an zu brennen.
So nahm das Ganze seinen Anfang.
Kaum zu glauben:
Trotz schweren Verletzungen
setzt sie sich an den Computer
und arbeitet weiter.
Also mir war ziemlich bald klar, als
ich mich im Spiegel gesehen habe,
dass es nicht ganz so trivial ist.
Ich habe
einen Kessel Wasser mitgenommen,
von unten, aus der Waschküche.
Ich hielt die ganze Zeit
meine rechte Hand rein.
Es war zum Glück schön kalt.
Das Gesicht
habe ich mit Waschlappen ...
... mit kalten Waschlappen
abgedeckt.
Meine linken Zehen
waren auch völlig verbrannt.
Da habe ich entschieden,
dass ich das ignoriere,
um den Jahresabschluss zu machen.
Das war ein bewusster Entscheid.
Ich war so in einer
Leistungsbereitschaft,
dass kommen konnte, was wollte,
zuerst kam das Geschäft,
nachher alles andere.
Ich wollte es gut machen.
Ich wollte nicht, dass
irgendetwas im Geschäft leiden muss,
nur weil ich diesen Unfall hatte.
Am späten Nachmittag
wird Doris Brülhart
ins Unispital Zürich gebracht.
Zweieinhalb Wochen
wird sie dort behandelt.
Zu Hause, in der Heilungsphase,
folgt der nächste Schlag.
Danach kam ein Anruf
von meinem damaligen Chef.
Es gebe komische Gerüchte,
die die Runde machten
und Vorwürfe gegen mich.
Dass ich Geld unterschlagen hätte.
Da bin ich total erschrocken.
Das hat mich völlig
aus den Socken gehauen.
Das fand ich ganz schlimm.
Ich ertrug es überhaupt nicht.
Ich hatte riesige Ängste,
was das wohl ...
... was die gemeint
haben könnten, was da ist.
Es war übel, ganz übel.
Es hat mich im Innersten getroffen.
Diese Bilder hat Doris Brülhart
während der Produktion
eines Werbespots gedreht,
den sie auf dem Höhepunkt
ihrer Karriere produzieren liess.
Sie arbeitete
für ein internationales Unternehmen
im Gesundheitsbereich.
Der aufwändige Spot
wurde zum Ursprung des Verdachts,
es sei Geld verschwunden.
Eine Revision
entlastete Doris Brülhart,
sie blieb Geschäftsführerin,
fühlte sich aber kontrolliert
und zutiefst verunsichert.
Das waren ganz diffuse Ängste.
Schlussendlich
ging es um meine Existenz,
um meine Existenz,
aber auch um meine Reputation.
In dieser Zeit
wurde mein Mann entlassen.
Da fühlte ich mich verantwortlich
für die Existenz dieser Familie.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Doris Brülhart machte weiter,
funktionierte mithilfe
von Medikamenten so gut es ging.
Ein Kampf auf verlorenem Posten.
Meine Psychologin hat mir wirklich
gesagt, es gehe so nicht.
"Sie kommen so
nicht aus der Situation raus."
Und sie hat mir gesagt: "Klinik.
Etwas anderes kommt nicht infrage."
Doris Brülhart wurde krankgeschrie-
ben, später folgt die Kündigung.
Ihre Diagnose: Angststörung.
Denn medizinisch gilt Burnout
nicht als eigenständige Krankheit,
sondern nur als Symptom
von psychischen Beschwerden.
Die Zahl der Absenzen
aus psychischen Gründen
steigt in der Schweiz dramatisch an -
um 58 % in den letzten 10 Jahren.
Wir hatten bei der Arbeit
gewisse Umstrukturierungen.
Und dort hatte ich eine gewisse
Verantwortungsposition.
Das Ganze
war mit viel Stress verbunden.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich war
mega Feuer und Flamme für das.
Ich habe es sehr gerne gemacht.
Aber die Umstrukturierungen haben
einfach so viel Kraft gebraucht.
Und das war die Zeit,
als ich auch Papi wurde.
Es ist etwas mega Schönes,
Papi zu sein.
Aber auch etwas unglaublich An-
strengendes, gerade im ersten Jahr.
So hatte ich gar keine Momente mehr,
wo ich mich erholen konnte.
Die Reizbarkeit und
latente Aggression begann,
überhand zu nehmen.
Irgendwann
kam das ganze zum Höhepunkt.
Plötzlich ist der Staudamm gebrochen
und der ganze Stress,
der sich angesammelt hatte,
kam auf einmal raus.
Als das vorbei war,
bin ich komplett zusammengebrochen.
Meine damalige Frau
ging mit dem Kind zu einer Freundin.
Das war der Moment,
als ich dachte,
ich brauche jetzt Hilfe.
Ein Freund fährt ihn in die Klinik.
Eray Cansev bekommt Medikamente,
entscheidet sich aber
gegen einen stationären Aufenthalt.
Ein paar Wochen versucht er noch,
weiter zu unterrichten.
Dann kündigt er,
ohne dass der Arbeitgeber
von seinem Burnout erfährt.
Fast dreiviertel Jahre
liegt der Zusammenbruch zurück.
Manchmal rafft sich Eray Cansev auf,
Musik zu machen.
Oft aber verschläft er den Tag.
Seit Monaten lastet
eine schwere Depression auf ihm.
* Sphärische Klänge *
Noch am gleichen Tag
macht er sich auf den Weg,
um wieder in der
Psychiatrie Hilfe zu suchen.
Nennen wir ihn Daniel U. 46.
Er ist auf Stellensuche,
will deshalb anonym bleiben.
Sein Burnout zeigt sich
nach einer happigen Kritik des Chefs.
Es sind so Aussagen gefallen wie,
ich hätte jemandem den gestreckten
Mittelfinger gezeigt.
Was eigentlich nicht möglich ist.
Ich mache das höchstens beim Auto-
fahren und dann sieht es niemand.
Auch die persönlichen Angriffe
auf mich, als man sagte,
ich ginge unfreundlich um - unflätig
war das Wort, das man benutzt hat.
Und hätte meine Arbeit
vernachlässigt.
Was ich ganz anders gesehen habe.
Es ist so, dass ich eine relativ
deutliche Ausdrucksweise habe.
Also da kommt
schon mal ein Wort vor,
das man nicht unbedingt senden kann.
Ich habe auch bei meinem
Vorstellungsgespräch gesagt,
dass ich sehr direkt kommuniziere.
Ich sehe das als Stärke
und auch als Schwäche.
Und es kann schon mal sein, dass
jemand pikiert ist, wenn ich sage:
"Hör mal, jetzt einfach nicht."
"Momentan bin ich überlastet,
lass mich in Ruhe."
Ich bin aber auch der Erste,
der sich entschuldigt,
wenn ich das merke und weiss,
wen es betrifft.
Das geht nicht, das ist mir bewusst.
Daniel U. leitet als Metallarbeiter
ein kleines Team.
Nach einer Ohrenoperation
fühlt er sich gesundheitlich
angeschlagen und überfordert.
Die Vorwürfe des Chefs
setzen ihm extrem zu.
Der entscheidende Punkt war,
als ich um 1 Uhr nach einer Stunde
Schlaf erwacht bin.
Ich wollte aus dem Zimmer raus,
damit ich meine Frau nicht wecke.
Ich begann zu weinen,
obwohl ich nicht wusste, warum.
Es hat mich ziemlich belastet.
Ich begann an mir zu zweifeln.
* Schweres Ausatmen *
(Mit belegter Stimme) Ich konnte
nicht mehr mit mir umgehen.
Das ist das, was mich
so aus der Bahn geschmissen hat.
Auch jetzt,
wo ich wieder darüber rede.
Für mich war das Thema
eigentlich abgeschlossen.
Es wühlt mich doch immer wieder auf,
wenn ich darüber nachdenke.
Es gab dann einen Tag, wo er
in einem Zustand zur Arbeit ging,
wo ich mir den ganzen Morgen
Sorgen gemacht habe,
dass ich ihn
auf die Strasse gehen liess.
Das hat mich so beschäftigt,
dass ich zuerst
seine Eltern angerufen habe,
um mal mit jemandem zu reden.
Dann habe ich gedacht:
"Jetzt muss ich handeln."
"Wenn etwas passiert, könnte ich
mir das nie im Leben verzeihen."
Dann habe ich gesagt: "Du musst als
Erstes aus der Schusslinie raus."
Egal, was kommt.
"Es bringt nichts,
wenn du im Geschäft zusammenbrichst
oder einen Unfall baust."
"Du  k a n n s t  jetzt gar nichts
mehr auf die Reihe kriegen."
Seine Partnerin
begleitet Daniel U. zum Hausarzt.
Er wird krankgeschrieben
und besucht einen Psychiater.
In dem Gespräch ging es nur darum,
ob man mich in einer Psychi
"versorgen" sollte.
Das hat für mich
einfach nicht funktioniert.
Ich wollte zurück an die Arbeit,
so schnell wie möglich.
Das war für mich der springende
Punkt - absolut wichtig.
Obwohl Daniel U. nach einer kurzen
Absenz wieder zur Arbeit geht,
wird ihm gekündigt.
Jetzt braucht er praktische Hilfe
bei der Rückkehr in den Arbeitsmarkt.
Genau das bietet WorkMed in Liestal.
Eine Fachstelle,
spezialisiert auf psychische Probleme
in der Arbeitswelt.
Therapiestunde mit Barbara Aebersold.
Ihr Thema, das Sie gewählt haben,
ist der Umgang mit Leuten
in schwierigen Situationen.
Ja, v.a. so mühsame Leute für mich,
mit denen ich im Umgang Mühe habe.
Z.B. als die Kündigung
ausgesprochen wurde,
fiel ich brutal in ein Loch
und reagierte auch sehr schlecht.
Ich fluchte meinen Chef an -
ich möchte diverse Wörter,
die dort fielen,
nicht wiederholen.
So ein gekränkter Stolz irgendwie.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob das der richtige Ausdruck ist.
Ich musste aufstehen, weil ich
sonst zu weinen angefangen hätte.
Und als ich mich wieder umdrehte,
war ich ein Teufel mit zwei Hörnern.
Also eigentlich immer wieder
in so Situationen,
in der Sie gekränkt werden oder
sich ungerecht behandelt fühlen ...
Genau das ist der Punkt.
... dann kommt die Reaktion,
wo Sie schnell explodieren
und Sachen sagen,
die Sie im Nachhinein
nicht mehr sagen würden?
Richtig, genau.
- Die Sie danach bereuen?
Genau. Das ungerechte Behandeln,
das ist ein Punkt,
der begleitet mich
schon das ganze Leben lang.
Das ist einer der Punkte,
warum ich hier bin.
Ich sage einem, den ich nicht mag,
nicht, dass ich ihn nicht mag.
Sondern er ist dann ein Arsch.
Dass das ein Vorgesetzter
nicht wahnsinnig lässig findet,
kann ich mir schon vorstellen.
Ich sehe nicht ein,
warum ich das nicht sagen soll.
Er darf ja auch etwas lernen.
Wie können Sie ruhig bleiben?
Wenn ich das wüsste,
wäre ich nicht hier.
Sie haben es schon mal geschafft,
bei Ihrer letzten Stelle.
Sie haben mir erzählt,
dass Sie das mit dem Zählen
ausprobiert haben.
Ja, genau.
Und zwar innerlich für sich
von eins auf zehn zu zählen.
Ja.
Und auch am Schluss:
"Danke für das Gespräch"
oder "Danke für die Auskunft".
Danke für was?
Freundlich bleiben.
Ich gebe mir Mühe,
da mitzuarbeiten. Auf jeden Fall.
Besten Dank.
- Danke.
Workmed ist eine Aussenstelle
der Psychiatrie Baselland.
Ihr Leiter Niklas Baer gilt
als Pionier der Arbeitspsychiatrie.
Er will niederschwellig Hilfe bieten
und vermitteln zwischen Betroffenen
und ihren Arbeitgebern.
Der Begriff Burnout
ist ihm zu schwammig.
Für die Leute ist es wichtig,
dass sie sagen können:
"Ich hatte ein Burnout."
D.h. irgendwie:
"Ich habe zu viel gearbeitet"
oder "Der Arbeitgeber
hat mich nicht gut behandelt".
"Das Resultat ist,
dass ich ein Burnout habe."
Aber wenn man die Situationen
genauer anschaut,
dann ist es praktisch nie
einfach nur das.
Wenn man jetzt im Moment
schauen würde,
dann könnte man
bei jedem fünften Mitarbeiter
in einem Schweizer Unternehmen
eine psychische Krankheit
diagnostizieren.
D.h., die allermeisten Leute
mit einer psychischen Krankheit
oder Problematik arbeiten.
Und häufig auch gut.
Das ist so häufig,
dass man einen anderen Zugang
zum Thema finden müsste.
Und nicht einfach:
"Ich darf nicht darüber reden."
Das ist nicht logisch,
wenn jeder vierte oder fünfte
so eine Problematik hat.
Entscheidend ist,
wie jemand damit umgeht.
Doris Brülhart kämpft sich zurück.
Da braucht man ganz viel Lavendel.
Ab nächstem Sommer kann ich
Lavendel aus dem Garten verwenden.
Mit selbst produzierten
Naturkosmetikprodukten
will sie sich selbständig machen.
Was hast du reingetan?
Riech mal.
Als ich runterkam,
roch es nach Dope.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es das ist.
- Nein.
Pfefferminz?
Boah, puh!
Dings, ich kenne den Geruch.
Ich kann es nicht zuordnen.
Es ist blau.
- Lavendel.- Genau.
Es ist fantastisch.
Jetzt beginnt es zu tröpfeln.
Es ist etwas Fantastisches,
wenn man erkältet ist.
Nein, zum beruhigen.
- Aber für Erkältungen ...
Zum beruhigen, aber
es wirkt auch entzündungshemmend.
Wieso weisst du das alles?
- Weil ich Drogistin bin.
Weisst du,
was ich entspannend finde?
Dem zuzuschauen,
wie es runtertropft.
Sehr befriedigend.
- Das gefällt mir auch.
Endlich ist Ruhe eingekehrt
in der Familie.
Doris Brülharts Ehemann hat
ein eigenes Unternehmen gegründet
und unterstützt sie daneben
beim Aufbau ihres Geschäfts.
Der Zusammenbruch ist Vergangenheit.
Diese Krise war bei ihr
sozusagen von aussen angetriggert.
Das hat in ihr etwas bedient, was
offensichtlich schon angelegt war
und dann
sozusagen zum Vorschein kam.
Ich glaube, dass sie enorm arbeits-
tüchtig und pflichtbewusst ist.
Und wenn man der Mama
etwas sagt und gibt, eine Aufgabe,
dann will sie die auch erfüllen.
Ich glaube, sie macht sich
einen ziemlichen Druck,
um die zu erfüllen.
Manchmal ist es ein Druck,
der so okay ist,
ja, der ist da,
aber ich mache es gern.
Aber es gibt auch den Druck,
der von aussen kommt.
Wenn der Druck mit ihrem zusammen
kommt, dann ist es zu viel.
Dann bricht sie zusammen.
Ich denke, das funktioniert
bei ganz vielen Menschen.
Man muss nur die richtigen
Schrauben drehen, Druck aufsetzen,
dann brechen viele ein.
Die Frage ist eher:
Warum wird das überhaupt gemacht?
Im Keller sind die Gefässe für das
Kerzenziehen einem Labor gewichen.
Doris Brülhart
setzt auf die Selbständigkeit.
Ein Wagnis, das sie entspannt angeht.
Hier tüftelt sie an Produkten
für das Sortiment ihrer neuen Firma.
Von Shampoo über Körpercrème
bis zu dieser Fusssalbe.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Es ist schon etwas Wunderschönes.
Etwas aus sich erschaffen,
selber die Idee haben.
Es umsetzen und nachher das Resultat
in den Fingern zu haben,
ein Fläschchen
mit kosmetischen Produkten -
das tut mir wahnsinnig gut.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Eray Cansev hat die Behandlung
in der Tagesklinik beendet.
Er ist aber noch weit entfernt
von einem normalen Alltag.
Wann gingst du schlafen?
- Am Morgen.
Als die Sonne aufging?
- Ja.
Ich bin froh, dass ich
überhaupt wieder gut schlafen kann.
Weil ich ja Zeiten
mit mega Schlafstörungen hatte,
in denen ich mega oft aufgewacht bin
oder mega abstruse Träume hatte
und mich nicht mehr getraut habe,
zu schlafen.
Also letzte Woche?
- Ja, vor zwei Wochen.
Er überlegt, ob ihn eine Reise in die
Türkei, die Heimat seiner Eltern,
aus der Depression reissen könnte.
Ein Cousin hat ihn eingeladen.
Die Türkei hast du gebucht?
Noch nicht.
Ich bin immer noch unsicher.
Ich traue fast nicht zu buchen.
Wahrscheinlich würde es mir
einen Schub geben,
um etwas sicherer zu sein.
Es ist eine mega Überwindung.
Es ist etwas mega Grosses für mich.
Nach all dieser Zeit ...
ist es ein Riesenberg,
den ich erklimmen würde.
Ich war so lange im Kokon, in der
Komfortzone, in der Sicherheit.
Das Schwierige an der momentanen
Situation ist vielleicht,
dass es ihm nicht gut geht.
Es ist in diesem Sinne wie ...
Es ist ja nichts Neues mehr,
das Erleben der Symptome.
Es ist ein wenig gefährlich,
aber man gewöhnt sich daran.
Jetzt ist es vielleicht
eher der chronische Zustand.
Das Problem ist halt,
in Gruppen geht es fast nicht mehr.
Wenn wir uns als Freundeskreis
treffen, zu viert oder fünft,
dann wird er sehr schnell müde, ist
überfordert und zieht sich zurück.
Also wenn man zusammen isst, ist er
nach dem Essen grad auf der Couch.
Das ist die Schwierigkeit.
Einerseits sich zu verabreden ...
Man muss halt sehr flexibel sein.
Man denkt immer oder hofft,
dass es niemandem verleidet,
dass es zu lange geht.
Aber bisher haben die Freunde
immer zu mir gehalten.
Dafür bin ich unglaublich dankbar.
Nach so einer langen Zeit
ist vieles schon ausgesprochen.
Und es verändert sich
nicht so schnell so viel.
Vielleicht geht es beim Umfeld auch
darum, Strukturen zu schaffen,
die einen
aus den Gedanken rausholen,
damit man nicht auf dem Bett liegt
und es ständig dreht.
Eray Cansev hat Hilfe
von Freunden und Therapeuten.
Aber für eine Rückkehr
ins Arbeitsleben
fühlt er sich noch nicht in der Lage.
Wer gegen psychische Probleme kämpft,
bleibt dem Arbeitsleben
viel länger fern
als bei fast allen
anderen Krankheiten.
Im Durchschnitt dauert
die Arbeitsunfähigkeit sechs Monate.
Auch Doris Brülhart brauchte Zeit.
Sie fand Hilfe in der Klinik Hohenegg
in Meilen und kehrt jetzt zurück,
um die Pflegefachfrau
Svenja Ziehl-Berndorff zu besuchen,
die sie
durch die schwere Zeit begleitet hat.
Wenn ich es
auf den Punkt bringen müsste,
war es zuerst mal eine Insel.
Eine rettende Insel,
auf der es rundherum Schutz gab.
Vor all dem,
was mir vorher solche Angst machte
und mich so kaputt machte.
Wenn irgendetwas war,
dann ging ich zu ihr.
Sie hat eine Art Rahmen
um alles herum gemacht.
Zehn Wochen
dauerte ihr Aufenthalt in der Klinik.
Ich habe ganz praktische Tools
mit auf den Weg bekommen.
Z.B. Fingeratemübungen.
Ich weiss jetzt, warum Angela Merkel
immer die Raute macht.
Mutti!
Da kann man z.B.
Fingeratemübungen machen.
Also dann, wenn es ganz heftig wird.
Ich habe mal eine heftige Situation
erlebt und ging zu Svenja.
Sie hat mir sofort gesagt:
"Wir gehen in einen Raum."
Sie kam mit dieser Matte.
Das ist jetzt meine.
Ich habe sie mitgenommen,
weil ich verbinde mit Svenja
so sehr diese Matte.
Nachher hat sie sie
auf den Boden gelegt.
Dann sollte ich
auf die Matte stehen.
Wenn man da drauf steht,
dann tut das wirklich richtig weh.
Dann hat man gar keine Zeit mehr,
oder keine Möglichkeit mehr
in der Angst zu sein.
Das gibt so einen starken Reiz,
dass die ganze Aufmerksamkeit
in den Füssen,
in diesem Reiz, im Schmerz drin ist.
Das hat mir in dieser Situation
wahnsinnig geholfen.
Wir nennen es Skills, Fertigkeiten,
Fähigkeiten,
um Anspannung zu regulieren.
Da gibt es so viele Möglichkeiten.
Da gilt es herauszufinden, wie ich
eben sagte, was bist du für ein Typ.
Bist du jemand,
der was riecht gerne?
Bist du jemand, der visuell sehr
stark ist, der ins Spüren kommt,
der über den Geschmack
gut zu erreichen ist?
Wir versuchen den Zugangskanal
herauszufinden,
um über Sinnesreize zu spüren,
dass es da auch noch
was anderes gibt ausser dem,
das gerade die Panik,
die Anspannung auslöst.
Raus aus der Situation. Das ist
Sinn und Zeck dieser Skills.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Dank verschiedener Therapien
kam Doris Brülhart im geschützten
Rahmen wieder auf die Beine.
Und doch bleibt ihr Verhältnis
zur Psychiatrie zwiespältig.
Ich hatte manchmal das Gefühl,
die Hohenegg ist eigentlich
eine wunderbare Institution
des Neokapitalismus,
um die Leute
dann wieder auf Spur zu bringen.
Damit sie hinterher wieder
so voll den Rubel rollen lasse.
Es ist eigentlich
nur eine Flickwerkstatt.
Jein.
- Was ins System reingehört.
Das war, wenn ich wieder mal
so richtig stinkesauer war
auf dieses neoliberale Wirtschafts-
gebaren, in dem wir stecken.
Neoliberales Wirtschaftsgebahren?
Was läuft falsch in den Unternehmen?
Es gäbe natürlich
sehr viel Raum für Vorgesetzte,
zu reagieren.
Der Normalfall ist,
dass sie sehr spät wirklich auf den
Mitarbeiter zugehen oder gar nicht.
Und häufig erst zu einem Zeitpunkt,
in dem das Geschirr
schon zerschlagen ist.
Nur ein paar Wochen sind vergangen,
seit Eray Cansev mit seinem Freund
Marc überlegt hat,
ob er verreisen soll.
Wochen, die alles verändert haben.
Es geht mir recht gut.
Viel besser als das letzte Mal.
Ich bin
das Leben wieder am einrichten.
Überhaupt
wieder ins Leben zurückzufinden.
Das ist für mich mega erfreulich,
etwas mega Schönes.
Ich war in der Türkei.
Ich war zwei Wochen dort.
Mit dem Cousin an einem Ort, wo es
sehr viel Natur hatte, schöne Natur.
Während des Aufenthalts
tankte ich sehr viel Sonne,
sehr viel gute Energie.
Auch das Meer nahm Lasten von mir
und spülte sie weg.
Ich habe mich mit Leben und Freude
erfüllt gefühlt.
Ich glaube, die Distanz
hat auch ermöglicht,
dass ich eine ganz andere
Perspektive einnehmen kann,
wenn über darüber nachdenke,
was alles passiert ist.
Dann überhaupt das Gefühl:
Wow, ich habe dort eine Familie.
Die stehen zu mir
und sind für mich da.
Man vergisst das, wenn man da lebt
und eine Distanz zu ihnen hat.
Dann fühlt man sich so, wow,
ich kann jetzt entspannen.
Und all die Sachen haben das Feuer
wieder entfacht in mir,
von dem ich das Gefühl hatte,
das sei ausgelöscht.
Auf dem Weg zu einem Termin
bei der IV-Beratung in Aarau.
Astrid Bujards Ziel ist die
Wiedereingliederung ihres Klienten.
35 Coaching-Stunden
stehen zur Verfügung.
Als ich gemerkt habe,
ich habe wieder Energie,
was ich seit eineinhalb Jahren
nicht mehr hatte,
habe ich gedacht,
ich muss das gleich nutzen.
Ich fing an, Jobs anzuschauen.
Schon in der Türkei
schauten Sie sich um?- Ja.
Aber zuerst eigentlich so mega,
wie unvoreingenommen,
Im Sinne von ich schaue mal.
Dann habe ich gesehen, oh mein Gott,
es hat Jobs, die mich interessieren.
Dann wusste ich, ich muss mich
bewerben, wenn die Chance da ist.
Eben, das mit der Klinik
hat sich erübrigt.
Wo haben Sie sich beworben?
Zwei höhere Fachschulen,
bei denen ich mich beworben habe.
Sie suchen einen nebenberuflichen
Mathematik-Dozenten,
maximal acht Lektionen pro Woche.
Das klang für Sie wie ein Pensum,
das realistisch sein könnte?
Ja, für den Anfang sicher.
Es ist klar, dass ich
langfristig mehr haben muss.
Für den Einstieg ...
- Aber für den Einstieg ist super.
Noch die Fragen zu speziellen
Stärken und Schwächen,
was sagen Sie dazu?
Ich sage, ich bin mega ...
Ich gebe mich mega rein
in eine Sache,
bin Feuer und Flamme,
das ist eine Stärke.
Aber wenn das zu stark wird,
brenne ich aus.
Irgendwann muss man sich überlegen,
wie effizient ist die Energie,
die man rein gibt.
Wie effizient
wird das noch umgesetzt.
Ich müsste den richtigen
Arbeitspunkt finden,
von Energie, die man rein gibt
und wie viel dabei rauskommt.
Die Beraterin empfiehlt Eray Cansev,
seine psychischen Probleme
in den Bewerbungsgesprächen
offen anzusprechen.
Wir sagen, wir wollen schnell
und nachhaltig sein.
Wir suchen die Stelle,
die passt für den Kandidaten.
Wo er oder sie sich wohlfühlt.
Ein Umfeld,
das auch der Problematik entspricht.
Oder wo man
mit der Problematik umgehen kann.
Wo man bereit ist,
miteinander zu arbeiten.
Adieu.
- Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Stigma psychische Krankheiten.
In einer repräsentativen Umfrage
wünschen sich 90 % der
Arbeitgeberinnen und Arbeitgeber,
dass solche Störungen im Vorstel-
lungsgespräch angesprochen werden.
Aber nur 60 % der Arbeitgeber würden
diese Personen auch anstellen.
Es ist eigentlich völlig falsch,
dass man abgeschrieben wird,
z.B. um Karriere zu machen,
wenn man sich mal geoutet hat,
dass man Probleme hat.
Eigentlich sollte das
ein Pluspunkt sein.
Entscheidend ist ja nicht,
ob jemand irgendwann
ein psychisches Problem hat.
Sondern, wie er damit umgeht.
Und so ein aktives und
verantwortungsvolles Verhalten
in so einer Situation,
wo man Probleme hat,
das qualifiziert eigentlich
für eine Karriere.
Workmed bietet nicht nur Abklärungen
und Therapie,
sondern auch Prävention.
Niklas Baer mit einer Kollegin auf
dem Weg ins Spital Bethesda in Basel.
Das Publikum der Veranstaltung:
Berufsbildnerinnen und Berufsbildner
aus allen Bereichen des Spitals.
Niklas Baer
geht es um eine Entkrampfung
im Umgang
mit psychischen Beschwerden.
Grüezi mitenand.
Ich freue mich sehr,
dass Barbara Schmocker und ich
heute da sein dürfen.
Ich habe mich sehr gefreut über
die Anfrage, mit Ihnen das Thema
psychisch auffällige Jugendliche
zu besprechen in den nächsten 2 Std.
Ich finde es super,
dass Sie das machen.
Was insgesamt finden Sie
am schwierigsten,
wenn es um den Umgang mit psychisch
auffälligen Lernenden geht?
Das Schwierigste im Umgang
mit einem Lernenden ist,
dass man das Problem
überhaupt mal anspricht,
ohne dem Lernenden
zu nahe zu treten.
Meistens haben sie
keine Betreuung und Diagnose,
wenn sie zu uns kommen.
Wir stellen eine Auffälligkeit fest.
Und wie kann ich die Leute
dazu bewegen, den Weg zu gehen?
Wie kann ich die Lernenden dazu
bewegen, Unterstützung anzunehmen?
Bei mir ist es immer so,
dass die Lernenden
nicht nur mir negativ auffallen,
sondern auch der Abteilung
oder im Team.
Inwiefern muss ich sie schützen,
sagen, es ist alles in Ordnung?
Es ist nur mir bekannt. Und wie weit
informiere ich das Team?
Müssen die auch Bescheid wissen?
Super, danke vielmal. Wir haben alle
zentralen Themen aufgeschrieben.
Die psychischen Störungen treten
bei der Hälfte aller Betroffenen
zum ersten Mal in der Jugend auf.
D.h.: Die Berufsbildnerinnen
und Berufsbildner
können wichtige Weichen stellen,
wenn sie die Beschwerden
rechtzeitig erkennen.
Am frühesten zeigen sich
psychische Auffälligkeiten
im zwischenmenschlichen Kontakt.
Viel früher als bei der Leistung.
Und noch viel früher
als bei Absenzen.
So feine,
zwischenmenschliche Spannungen.
Dort müssen Sie hinschauen.
Die müssen Sie ernst nehmen,
dort müssen Sie reagieren.
Das ist das Früheste.
Es gibt Leute,
die sind psychisch nicht krank
und bringen noch
viele Ressourcen mit.
Sie sind fröhlich, lustig, usw.
Gratuliere - mit denen
haben wir keine Probleme.
Dann gibt es Leute, rechts oben,
die sind psychisch krank.
Vielleicht
sind sie sogar schwer erkrankt.
Aber sie bringen
viele Ressourcen mit.
Sie sind motiviert, verlässlich,
offen für Lösungen.
Und dann kann man sagen,
das sind Leute,
die machen das Beste
aus einer schwierigen Situation.
Und ich würde sagen,
das sind nicht die Lernenden,
mit denen Sie die grössten Probleme
haben. Einverstanden?
Obwohl sie psychisch krank sind.
Aber sie bringen viel mit.
Dann gibt es Leute,
die sind psychisch nicht krank.
Aber sie bringen
wenig Ressourcen mit.
Sie sind nicht so interessiert.
Sie sind nicht so freundlich,
so zuverlässig.
Und dann gibt es Leute,
die haben beides.
Die haben eine psychische Krankheit
und bringen wenig Ressourcen mit.
Das wäre nicht selten der Fall
z.B. bei Persönlichkeitsstörungen.
Wir würden Ihnen empfehlen,
dass Sie weniger schauen,
was er
an psychischen Krankheiten hat,
sondern, wie er sich verhält.
Das dürfen Sie auch.
Sie dürfen
auf Verhalten und Leistung schauen.
Sie müssen nicht rausfinden,
was er hat.
Ist es Borderline oder Bulimie?
Aber
das Verhalten und die Leistung,
das dürfen und müssen Sie
ansprechen.
Foto-Shooting im Zürcher Unterland.
Cermony ist ja nicht perfekt.
Perfekt macht krank.
Lächle wie Mona Lisa.
Mit diesen Bildern
will Doris Brülhart
ihre selbst produzierten
Naturkosmetika bewerben,
die sie in einer ersten Phase
in einem Web-Shop verkauft.
(Lachend) Mona-Lisa-Lächeln!
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Der Ausbruch der Pandemie
hat ihren Elan nicht gebremst.
Das Geschäftslokal liegt am Flughafen
Zürich, im neuen Komplex The Circle.
Es laufen
die letzten Vorbereitungsarbeiten.
Hier soll
eine Wohlfühloase entstehen.
Bliss, so der Name des Ladens Ð
heisst: Glückseligkeit.
Im Angebot hat sie Massagen,
Manicure und Pedicure,
und natürlich die selbst-
hergestellten Kosmetikprodukte.
Allerdings zögert Corona
die Eröffnung immer weiter hinaus.
Wir haben keinen Umsatz,
d.h. wir haben viele Kosten.
Schon rein vom Bau her.
Wir haben kein Einkommen
in der ganzen Zeit.
Das ist nicht lustig.
Das ist wirklich nicht lustig.
Im Geschäft steckt das eigene
Vermögen und Geld von Verwandten.
Wann zu den Ausgaben
endlich Einnahmen kommen, ist offen.
Das macht Angst.
Das gibt auch einen Druck.
Ich habe immer
einen Druck im Brustkorb gespürt.
Und das verspüre ich wieder.
Aber er vergeht auch wieder.
Das fühlt sich
sehr anders an als früher.
Früher war es permanent da.
Jetzt sind es sehr gesunde Gefühle,
die ich habe.
Ich kenne mich besser
und ich habe die Erfahrung,
dass wir ...
dass wir in der Lage sind,
mein Mann und ich,
alle die Hürden und Probleme
zusammen zu meistern.
Und ich bin mir meiner eigenen
Tatkraft auch bewusster.
Ich fühle mich
nicht mehr so ohnmächtig.
Sobald ich Ohnmachtsgefühle bekomme,
analysiere ich sie viel besser
und gehe ihnen auf den Grund.
Wenn ich an autoritäre Systeme
herangerate,
was durchaus passiert,
dann kann ich sie besser erkennen.
Doris Brülhart hat in der Krise
viel gelernt über sich selbst.
Das ist mein kleiner Flohmarkt,
den ich gebastelt habe.
Geduld braucht auch Daniel U.
Seine Kündigung fiel auf den Beginn
der Corona-Epidemie.
Seither schlägt er sich notgedrungen
die Zeit um die Ohren.
Die Therapie bei Workmed
ist beendet.
Die Rosen mussten wir selber
züchten, z.T. recht aufwändig.
Das ist die seltenste Blume.
Nach drei Monaten
habe ich vier Stück davon.
Es ist eine sog. Goldrose.
Es braucht ca. vier Zuchtvorgänge,
bis man eine solche bekommt.
Die Jobsuche
blieb bis heute erfolglos.
Ich bin sehr offen für Arbeiten,
ich habe keine fixe Richtung.
Ich habe
eine mechanische Ausbildung.
Ich habe auf dem Bau
eine Anlehre als Glaser absolviert.
Ich habe
einen Hausabwartskurs gemacht,
allerdings
nur den theoretischen Teil,
für den praktischen
hat es nicht mehr gereicht,
weil ich wieder arbeiten musste.
Das sind die richtigen Allrounder.
Sehr lässig wäre, auf einem Werkhof,
in einer Gemeinde zu arbeiten.
Oder Hauswartung,
irgendwo in diesem Bereich.
Ich will einfach etwas machen.
Ich merke das auch jetzt,
wo ich arbeitslos
respektive stellensuchend bin.
Ich will einen Ablauf haben.
Ich muss am Morgen aufstehen.
Ich muss raus in die Welt.
Ich muss mich gebraucht fühlen.
Das ist für mich
sehr entscheidend im Leben.
Auch Eray Cansevs Tage
sind wieder lang und leer.
Von Frau und Kind lebt er getrennt.
Sein Weg verläuft nicht geradlinig.
Ich hatte ja drei Vorstellungs-
gespräche. Die liefen super.
Ich habe alle drei Stellen bekommen,
also kleine Pensen im Lehrerberuf.
Für mich war das ja sowieso
auch der Traumberuf:
Mathematik unterrichten zu können
auf einem vergleichsweise
höheren Niveau.
Und das ging ein paar Monate gut.
Dann, im Dezember, war eine Phase,
wo meine Zwangssymptomatik
stark wurde.
Die wurde so stark, dass ich
Weihnachten, den 25. Dezember,
auf der Triage verbracht habe,
das war die Klinik Königsfelden
im Aargau.
Ich hatte einen Nervenzusammenbruch,
weil ich es nicht mehr ertragen habe
mit den Zwängen.
Die haben mich so fertig gemacht.
Die Zwangsstörung kennt Eray Cansev
seit der Jugend,
aber noch nie
war sie so stark wie jetzt.
Er muss sich immer wieder zwanghaft
am eigenen Körper berühren.
Ein dauernder Stress.
Und das ist vielleicht
zusammen mit Anforderungen,
sehr oft auch Anforderungen
von mir selber an mich,
in der Arbeit, zusammengekommen.
Es hat sich raufgeschaukelt.
Es folgte ein Klinikaufenthalt,
der keine Verbesserung brachte.
Die Abklärungen zeigten,
dass er seit Langem
an einer bipolaren Störung leidet.
Eray Cansev liess sich neurologisch
untersuchen Ð ohne Ergebnis.
Dank einer ambulanten Therapie
kann er den Alltag
einigermassen bewältigen.
Burnout wird immer so angeschaut,
wie wenn es
eine eigenständige Krankheit wäre.
Aber eigentlich,
in sehr vielen Fällen,
ist es
ein anderes Wort für eine Krise
nach einer längeren,
schwierigen Situation,
die immer schwieriger wurde.
Es ist sehr viel komplexer als:
"Ich habe zu viel gearbeitet."
Seit Ende des letzten Jahres
ist Doris Brülharts Geschäft
am Flughafen endlich offen.
Drei Jahre
nach ihrer grossen Krise.
Mir geht es wunderbar.
Ich bin voller Energie, voller
Adrenalin, voller Tatenkraft,
voller Freude, voller Dankbarkeit
all den Menschen,
die mich begleitet haben,
die mich unterstützt haben.
Das ist wirklich toll.
An den Eröffnungstagen
ist auch die Familie dabei.
Ich bin unglaublich stolz
auf meine Mutter,
dass sie das alles geschafft hat.
Das ist wunderschön,
das ist in sich stimmig.
Und ich bin
auch unglaublich beeindruckt,
dass sie das
alles alleine aufziehen konnte.
Bis heute lässt sich Doris Brülhart
therapeutisch begleiten.
Burnout ist vielmehr
als eine punktuelle Krise.
Schnelle Lösungen für die psychischen
Beschwerden gibt es nicht.
Schon wieder etwas geschafft.
Daniel U. - eineinhalb Jahre
nach der Kündigung
ist er immer noch auf Stellensuche.
Aus der persönlichen Krise aber
hat er herausgefunden.
Das Wichtigste überhaupt,
das zählt sicher für alle,
ist das familiäre Umfeld.
Dass man dort einen guten Halt hat
und offen darüber kommuniziert.
Das ist schwierig und fiel
mir am Anfang auch sehr schwer.
Ich war der Letzte, der sich
eingestand, dass er ein Burnout hat.
Das sind die wichtigsten Punkte,
dass man offen und ehrlich ist,
mit sich selber,
aber auch dem Umfeld gegenüber.
Dass man den Leuten
reinen Wein einschenkt,
zu seinem Problem steht
und es lösen will.
Und Eray Cansev?
Sein Zusammenbruch
liegt mittlerweile zwei Jahre zurück.
Er wartet auf einen Platz
in einem Arbeitsprogramm der IV
und ist beim RAV angemeldet.
Eigentlich möchte ich einfach
zur Ruhe kommen.
Ich habe gemerkt, dass es
für mich einfach Sinn macht ...
dass ich mir nicht immer das Gross-
artigste und Interessanteste
und weiss auch nicht was
machen muss im Leben.
Sondern, dass ich auch ...
... lernen kann, ein normales,
unspektakuläres, ruhiges,
routiniertes Leben zu führen.
So, dass es einfach
einmal easy ist.
Es muss auch nicht immer perfekt
sein. Es darf einfach easy sein.
* Sanfte Klänge *
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Liz Lei - 2022